While humans tend to think of themselves as the
smartest creatures on Earth, the animals in this video prove that sometimes we need a
little help from the other members of the Food Chain. From Man's best friend to the King of the Jungle,
prepare to be blown away by some
unbelievable animals that saved people's lives.
"Kahn To the Rescue": An average day in the backyard
nearly turned Into a nightmare for this Australian family. Only days after being introduced to his new home, Kahn,
a Doberman Pinscher, managed to save the life of 17
month-old Charlotte. The two were playing in the backyard when the pooch noticed a King Brown snake;
one of the world's deadliest
hiding underneath the house.
Sensing the danger, the dog quickly grabbed the child by the diaper and tossed it to safety.
For his heroic actions, Kahn received a bite on the paw. Luckily for him,
Charlotte's mother witnessed the entire incident and managed to rush the unlikely hero to the hospital in the nick of time.
"Dory The Rabbit":  Not many people can claim to have had their life saved by a rabbit.
However, this Englishman has probably told his story enough times to make up for it. Simon Steggall, a lifelong diabetic, fell
into a coma while watching television.
Within moments, his pet rabbit, Dory,
was jumping up and down on his chest in an attempt to wake him up. The animal's
peculiar behavior was enough to draw the attention of Stegall's wife, who quickly called the paramedics.
"Porpoises Save A Familiar Face": Film and television
actor, Dick van Dyke, revealed on The Craig Ferguson Show that in his younger years, a group of porpoises had managed to save
his life in an unlikely way. While lounging on a surfboard, van Dyke dozed off, only to wake up so far out, he could
no longer see the shore. As he began to paddle with the swells, he noticed a number of fins coming closer and closer...
Thankfully for him, and all of his fans, the fins turned out to be attached to a group of helpful
porpoises, which pushed the actor to safety. "Binti The Gorilla": A fun day at the zoo nearly turned deadly after a
three-year-old boy fell 18 feet
into a gorilla pit while visiting with his family. As the boy's mother rushed to the scene,  she noticed that some of the gorillas were
beginning to take an interest in their new pen mate.
That's when something shocking occurred! Binti, a 7-year-old female, picked the boy up and carried him
to the other side of the pit where zoo officials would have a better chance of retrieving him.
A miraculous feat for any animal, Binti's actions more than likely saved the boy's life from some of the more aggressive gorillas. "Saved By Lions":
While they have been defined more often than not for their ability to tear through flesh,
this particular pack of lions decided to abstain from their usual habits to save the life of a 12-year-old Ethiopian girl.
After being kidnapped by four men on her way home from school,
the girl
was saved when three lions chased away her abductors and stood guard until the police arrived.
One expert believes the pride may have mistaken the cries of the young girl for those of a lion cub, thus explaining why
they spared her life. Either way, the police may want to consider hiring the furry beasts as consultants.
"Kerry The Horse": It was just another day for
farmer, Fiona Boyd when she had to rely on the wits of her horse to survive a dangerous situation.
Fiona was attempting to move a cow and its calf from one spot to another, when the mother began to attack her.
Lying on the ground and fearing for her life, Fiona was saved by her horse, Kerry Gold. The creature had
been observing the situation and rushed to the aid of her owner. Kicking away the cow, Kerry did enough to allow her
owner to escape in the nick of time.
"Kilo The Pitbull": When a man posing as a FedEx driver attempted to push his way
into their Staten Island home, Justin Becker
and his dog Kilo sprang into action. As Becker slammed the intruder against the door, Kilo lunged at him, biting
ferociously. In a state of panic, the man shot the heroic Pitbull before running away. After rushing
into the hospital, it was determined that the wound wasn't serious, allowing Kilo to return home a hero.
"Dolphin Heroes": While swimming in the ocean with his daughter and two
of her friends, Rob House noticed something peculiar: a group of dolphins had begun to surround them...
Initially confused, House quickly realized that the dolphins
were attempting to herd him and his companions away from a 10-foot Great White shark swimming nearby.
The dolphins continued to protect the group for 40 minutes, only
dispersing after the enormous predator began to retreat. The ability of the finned creatures to sense danger
allowed this group of swimmers to escape unharmed.
"Winnie The Cat Sniffs Out Danger": After being woken up in the middle of the night by her cat,
Winnie, Cathy Keesling quickly sensed that something
was wrong. A water pump had broken while she and the rest of her family
were sleeping, causing poisonous carbon monoxide to fill their home. Her husband and son unconscious, Cathy immediately called 911.
Luckily for The Keeslings,  their cat, Winnie, noticed the change in the air and didn't waste any time alerting them to the danger.
"Mandy The Goat": When 78-year-old farmer, Noel Osborne fell Into a pile of manure, it was anything but funny.
The fall broke his hip, rendering him completely immobile. For the next five days, Noel
was kept alive by his goat Mandy.
She would allow him to drink her milk and would lie beside him at night to keep him
warm. While Noel would make a full recovery after being rescued by friends, he owes a debt of gratitude to Mandy and her
heroic actions.
Have you ever been saved by an animal? Tell us about it in the comment section and don't forget to subscribe to The Things!